So, what does it mean to understand a problem? And I should emphasize, we're
talking about computational problems here. And what all computational problems
have in common is that they have inputs and they have desired outputs. So,
problem is defined by the set of possible inputs. This is usually an infinite
set for most interesting problems and the relationships between those inputs and
the desired outputs. So, that means a solution to a problem is a procedure that
can take any input in that set and produces output, a desired output that
satisfies the relationship that we want. In this case, the relationship we want
is that the output is the number days between the birthday and the current date.
So, the first step to understanding a problem is to make sure that we understand
what the possible inputs are.